[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here
today i'm going to explain a norwegian
dark fantasy film called troll hunter
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie three
norwegian friends namely thomas johanna
and kalei are in a car
they study at the volder university
college and are about to make a
documentary about recent bear attacks
happening in the town as a college
project
kalei is the cameraman responsible for
shooting all the footage of their study
the three drive to the site where a
bear's dead body has been found and
interview local hunters interestingly
all the hunters have the same comment
they claim that the bear tracks look odd
and made up and assume that the head of
the norwegian wildlife board finn haugen
is hiding something the hunters also
share their mutual hatred for a fellow
hunter named hans whom all of them are
suspicious of
the comments make the students
documentary more interesting so they
decide to do more research on hans they
find out that hans lives in a campground
and interview his neighbor according to
the neighbor hans stays out most of the
night and doesn't return till sunrise
the group waits for him to return home
that day when they finally meet him they
ask for permission to go with him on one
of his night adventures
however hans strictly denies the idea
and asks them to go away the trio
notices marks from a potential bear
attack on hans's car and films it they
are adamant about finding out what hans
does at night so they wait in their car
nearby his van until it gets dark
at night hans gets into his car and
drives away as the group follows him
they drive behind his car the whole
night and see him board a ferry the next
day the group decides to get on the
ferry too when they reach the
destination they again follow him to a
hotel finally at night they see him get
into his car and drive away the trio
knows this is their chance to find out
what he is doing so they follow him
closely however they lose him after
reaching a gate that says that further
entrance is prohibited but the sign
doesn't stop the group as they open the
gate and go inside knowing that hans is
in there too they reach a dark and quiet
forest and get out of the car to look
for the hunter this strangely quiet
forest unsettles the group but they do
not stop the pursuit all of a sudden a
loud screech is heard and a bright light
flashes nearby the group freezes in
their tracks too scared to go check what
it is just then a terrified hans
approaches them hastily and asks them to
run away the group starts to run without
questioning him some unknown entity is
following them however the college
students do not know what the unknown
creature almost catches thomas and
injures him in the process but the group
manages to run away in hans's car
hans is quiet throughout the journey but
surprisingly accepts when the group asks
to join him for a hunt he then explains
that the entity that followed them
earlier is a mythological creature from
scandinavian folklore called trolls
trolls live in isolated rocks mountains
or caves hans describes them as ugly and
slow-witted creatures they always come
out at night because the light turns
them into rocks the trolls are
anti-christianity and can smell the
blood of people who believe in
christianity from afar hans finally
confesses that he isn't a bear hunter
but a troll hunter there is a massive
light mounted on his car which he uses
to turn the trolls into stone killing
them the group doesn't believe hans's
story but agrees to go with him on an
adventure the following night hans takes
the group on a troll hunt with him
before leaving he makes them rub troll's
smell on their body so the trolls
wouldn't smell humans hans carries a
flash gun that shoots out forceful uv
rays and they finally make their way
towards the forest
later hans gets a call from someone who
asks him to get a troll's blood sample
after walking for a while he asks the
group to stop at a place he plans to
bring out the trolls from their hidings
so he leaves the group and goes further
into the woods alone as the trio waits
for hans to return they start believing
that hans was just making up stories but
suddenly a loud growl is heard the trees
start shaking and a massive three-headed
creature emerges from between them the
group is terrified and starts running
towards their car while the troll
pursues them they finally reach the car
but the troll arrives there while
following their smell thankfully hans is
ready for the creature and flashes it
with the light mounted on his car the
creature immediately turns into stone
surprising the group thomas johanna and
kalei are excited to have found such a
brilliant being and believe that they
will be famous overnight because of the
camera footage
hans however is mad at the group for not
telling him that they are followers of
christianity that is why the troll could
smell and follow them however the trio
insists that none of them are christian
hans finally reveals that he doesn't get
paid enough for the hunts and doesn't
want to put his life in danger anymore
he wants to expose the truth about
trolls to the world and that is why he
agreed to bring them here the following
morning the head of the norwegian
wildlife board finn arrives at the scene
the group gets to know that finn
actually works for the troll security
service or tss the norwegian government
doesn't want the world to know about the
creature's existence so they have formed
a secret committee tss to solve any
problems related to trolls hans is an
official troll hunter who has been
appointed to kill trolls who come close
to humans hence to hide the deaths of
the trolls they cover it with bear
attack stories every news article about
the bear attacks till now has been a
cover-up for some trolls attack
hans reveals that for the past few weeks
trolls have been more aggressive than
usual and the tss wants to find out the
reason that is why they asked to collect
a troll's blood sample last night but
unfortunately hans was unsuccessful
so he wants to go for a hunt again today
finn realizes that the students are
filming the whole interaction and warns
them that they will not be allowed to
keep the footage but the warning doesn't
stop the trio
at night they go to a different location
to hunt the creature when they reach
there hans uses a sheep as bait to
attract the trolls the idea works and
after a while a different kind of troll
appears and starts devouring the sheep
hans dresses up in a metal suit and gets
a syringe he then bravely approaches the
creature to try to get his blood samples
hans manages to get the blood but angers
the troll in the process it attacks hans
and easily overpowers him it even tries
to eat the man but the metallic suit
resists it hans plays dead making the
troll leave the trio approaches him and
helps him up hans quickly follows the
troll and kills him by flashing his
light the next day they take the blood
samples to the lab to get them tested
and find out they will get the result
after some days the group then leaves
for another mission together they notice
several fallen trees and figure it is
the work of a troll they follow the
troll's footsteps and reach an abandoned
mine but before they can exit the mine a
family of trolls enters blocking their
way
the group is beyond terrified especially
the cameraman cauley who is shivering in
fear
he's not scared he's just a film student
and knows that camera shake makes
everything better he confesses that he
believes in christianity making the
group more nervous meanwhile the trolls
catch caulets scent and attack the group
they use the uv lights to somehow get
out of the mine but kalei is dragged in
by the creatures thomas and johanna sit
down on the ground unable to process
their friend's death
they take his broken camera and go back
to hans's trailer after some days they
hire a new muslim cameraman not sure how
the creature will react to her smell
finn calls hans again this time to
assign him a task to kill the most
dangerous troll of them all called the
yotnar who is easily 50 to 100 meters
tall hans knows this troll will be the
hardest to kill so he upgrades his van
with sharp metals to keep it away the
group travels to the mountains to look
for the troll on their pursuit they get
a call from the lab who reveals that the
trolls have rabies that is why they have
been overly aggressive over the past
month the group remembers that thomas
was bitten when he first encountered the
troll so they fear he might have rabies
too thomas claims he will get tested
once they get back just then they see
the yawtner troll making its way towards
their van unfortunately the van's
mounted lights stop working just then
hans thinks of a plan and starts singing
a christian hymn confusing the troll and
attracting it towards him they take this
opportunity to drive away after a while
hans manages to fix the lights they
drive right out from under the troll's
leg and finally manage to flash it with
the lights the troll turns into stone
and crumbles to the ground and the group
is relieved
thomas keeps the hard drive with the
footage of the documentary with him just
then finn and his men arrive and try
snatching the camera and the hard drive
from them thomas frantically snatches
them both and runs away leaving his
friends behind after a while he reaches
a road and sees a truck driving his way
the scene cuts as the screen goes black
an epilogue tells us that no one has
ever heard from the students since the
incident but we can assume that someone
from the truck took the footage from
thomas and leaked them to the press
with no options left norway's prime
minister confesses about the troll's
existence during a press meeting
at the end of the movie the whole world
knows about the trolls
now we just have to send someone after
bigfoot
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching